hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast using genomics to understand
human health and disease I am Rachel
Brown of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Richard
Myers dr. Myers received his BS in
biochemistry from the University of
Alabama in 1977 his PhD in biochemistry
from the university of california
berkeley in 1982 and he did his post
doctoral training at harvard university
he joined faculty of the ucsf medical
center in 1986 moved to Stanford
University in 1993 where he served as
professor and chair in the Department of
Genetics and director of the Stanford
human genome Center since 2008 dr.
Meyers has been president director and
faculty investigator of the Hudson alpha
Institute for biotechnology a nonprofit
research and teaching enterprise and
helps fill Alabama I will now turn it
over to dr. Meyers for his presentation
okay Thank You Rachel good morning
everyone i am i'm going to tell you
about how we use genomics and genetics
to study human biology problems both
health and disease and basic biology but
i'm going to give you a little
background
on on who we are first just because many
of you may not have heard of Hudson out
the Institute it's as Rachel said it's a
nonprofit research institute focused on
genomics and genetics we're funded by
grants and philanthropy sort of a soft
money place but foundations and some
support from the state we have 10
faculty members in our midst down but
soon about 15 15 or maybe 16 I mean
because we do genomics and and
large-scale problems both in human
biology as well as in plants and other
organisms oh it's a very collaborative
field so we work with people from all
over the world an unusual thing about
Hudson alpha is that we have biotech
companies as our associates there their
tenants and are on our same campus that
are the same building same campus there
28 of these and they most all are
involved in life sciences problems here
the faculty some of you may know some of
these folks we just now recruited a new
group of five faculty members from which
continent will be joining us this summer
here's a campus I'm always proud to show
this it this flagship building here is
where I on the lower left is where where
most of the research goes on the second
building behind that has has some of the
biotech companies as well as our our
data housing a conference center as well
and I'm we always like to point out this
is the world's largest double helix it's
a walkway that's a mile and a third down
and back that's sort of the center of
our park one thing about the way that we
do our work here is and many others I
think do large-scale genomics is we've
centralized all of our wet lab research
especially in ultra high throughput
sequencing this is run by dr. Shawn Levy
who is one of our faculty members here
very talented individual with a very
modest size team that runs now 24
next-generation DNA sequencing
change including the new alumina x10
which is the highest fastest one we've
done lots of a functional genomics as
well as lots of old genomes and partial
genome time they tell you a little bit
about that that's a photo of their team
and all of our work that we do in house
that we initiate and collaborators are
done through the services lab to make it
centralized and centralized data primary
data analysis as well as even some of
the detailed analyses but I should also
say that this team here is a services
lab does many many collaborations as
well as fee-for-service for literally
hundreds of now more than 2,000 projects
and and people from all over the world
all right so I'm going to tell you about
to talk about sort of two areas that I
sort of artificially divided genetics
and genomics and they're obviously very
related but let me talk about genetic
analysis and geneticists have been
essentially genome scientists for many
decades long before they can be Genome
Project but what's happened is that we
because increased knowledge as well as
vastly increased technology we can do
this on a much larger scale now so when
I think about genetics I'm thinking
about differences in DNA sequence that's
allelic variation so sequence variants
and of course most of us think about
those that were born with we got from
each parent one or either parent or both
parents as well as somatically acquired
ones especially in cancer but the immune
system undergoes somatic mutation as
well and there are probably others that
we don't even know about yet and what's
happened in recent years is that you
certainly we have for at least a couple
decades little longer have looked for
genes and identified genes involved in
at least in humans by by having
candidate genes and doing linkage
analysis etc but this has changed now
because we can look at targeted regions
and the whole exome all the exons and
coding regions of the genome and now and
hands with the new approaches that we're
doing whole genome sequences are frankly
to the same cost if not even less
expensive than the whole exome and then
there are other ways to think about this
because sometimes we're looking for not
just single base allelic variation but
bigger changes copy number variants and
other rearrangements and sequencing can
identify those but there are other tools
that we use and the field uses to really
work on those so let me tell you about
one example of targeted sequencing we do
this a lot for one gene or sets of genes
and sometimes hundreds of genes but this
is a very interesting one to end in its
technology that many others are around
the world are developing and using one
of the I think early proposes and
adopters of this is Jin Han one of our
faculty members are very talented
entrepreneurial and creative scientists
and he basically developed methods for
amplifying specific segments of the
genome by multiplex amplification
methods and started applying this to a
problem that people have been really
interested in Walker interested in for a
long time which is identifying can we
take peripheral blood from an individual
human that can be other organisms to and
determine all the antibodies and t-cell
receptors at least keepo keepo
components of our immune system can we
identify all of those and the concern
years ago was that this may be
impossible because we made their ten to
the fifteenth or more possibilities with
all the rearrangements going to that can
occur both of these gene systems as well
as in antibodies that hyper beaut
ability that occurs and and the other
kinds of changes that occur in t-cell
receptors and so would get with ultra
high throughput sequencing it became
possible to start thinking about doing
this so Jen develop ways of taking a
small amount of peripheral blood looking
the periphery and saying which
antibodies and t-cell receptors are
there so the interesting thing and he's
been applying this really for ten years
but especially these last few years is
sequencing has become cheaper and
cheaper and we really can do this so we
now routinely jen's
as well as others in many collaborations
take take a little bit of blood and in
two separate types of reactions measure
amplifying than sequence about 10
million 5 to 10 million sequence reads
for the t cell receptors and for in for
antibodies and this lower part of this
slide shows the panel up there just
showing the top let's say 500 so T cell
receptors and the height of the bars or
how much of each of those are made and
what gen noticed very early on when he
started looking at different diseases is
that when essentially every disease
looked at so far you get a greatly
reduced repertoire now so look in this
lower panel lower part with colon cancer
you see just a few clones that are
expressed in higher levels these other
clones from from the better present in
normal tissue are also present there
they're just present a lower fraction
considering now that many of these newer
ones are being made and there's sort of
hypothesis is that when you have
something that goes wrong that you start
making your immune system starts to try
to deal with that by making antibodies
sometimes or t-cell receptors or both
and you see this reduced repertoire so
here's another way to depict this in
this next slide it shows for individuals
in it and each one of these little oval
color of figures is is one of those
t-cell receptors in this case the t-cell
beta receptors and if you look into each
of these they this is maybe the top 500
or I don't know how many about a
thousand you see that there's an
enormous amount of diversity good
sequence deeper or make a bigger picture
and show many many more that our
president lower quantities but these are
the sort of the top few hundred and you
see a lot of diversity but if you look
at a disease in this one and certainly
if you look at cancer you look at many
other diseases you see a greatly reduced
repertoire like I showed in that earlier
slide and so you see large clones
appearing that are essentially look like
they're overtaking for the five million
or whatever number of sequence reads
that you're doing these are the ones
that end up dominating
again you see that everywhere in every
decision just another view of one of the
individuals who does not have a disease
and showing the difference in the
diversity so here's the thing that
surprised me when when Jen started doing
this and we started apply this to others
as well to dozens and maybe a hundred
150 individuals with particular diseases
started seeing some specific t-cell
receptors and anybody's that show up in
different individuals so this top panel
here of of maybe ten individuals 12
individuals you see in breast cancer you
see some t-cell receptors and you can't
see it from here but if you look at the
sequences of those those women share
similar amino acid sequences and their
t-cell receptors same is true for
antibodies as well so that that was
interesting because the idea that you
might be able to find disease-specific
signatures in the bloodstream against
within cells actually so you're not
looking for for cell free DNA or RNA
you're actually measuring it out of RNA
from the cells so that to me makes it a
very very valuable tool and so we're
applying this for all sorts of
phenotypes especially diseases but pre
and post drug treatment following the
progression of disease whether something
is recurring and we think it's going to
be one of the most powerful tools as
many other groups are doing as well I
will say one thing about these the amino
acids you heard me say the amino acid
sequences of these are variable regions
are identical are very similar in
different women with breast cancer let's
say in this case but what's interesting
is that the nucleic acid sequences are
different because of the redundancy of
the genetic code you can get the same
amino acid sequence to me that strikes
that speaks very strongly that this is
biologically relevant that's convergent
evolution you're converging in on t-cell
receptors or anybody's the same way to
try to attack a problem in different
individuals
so now I'm going to tell you about a
more now genome-wide sequencing and is
to solve or to work on a problem that
has been around forever but now is
tractable so here's just a little bit of
information this is a childhood genetic
disorders project that's led by dr. greg
cooper who is one of our faculty members
here I and Greg marsh and many others
here participated in this project i'll
tell you more about the people in a
minute but here's the problem is that if
you look worldwide about two to three
percent of kids who are born live boring
often have will have a problem sometimes
serious sometimes milder and these are
ones that are noticed that birds are not
long after birth many of those have to
do with with the nervous system our
neurons are probably the most delicate
organs and our cells in our bodies and
so often you have intellectual
disability intellectual delay
development lay other things these are
often syndromic you often have other
things that you can see and then in the
kids the guess is and now the data are
proving that the guess was that most of
these have a genetic contribute early
said maybe even of genetic cause meaning
a single gene or a small number of genes
this is important because for one thing
while one and a half two percent three
percent doesn't sound like a large
number maybe in the aggregate that is a
huge problem public health problem
worldwide and there are many things that
happen with this so so you don't know
the cause of most of these that's I
forgot to mention we know the causes of
maybe five or ten percent of all of all
of these disorders the vast majority we
don't know the causes we don't know the
change that are involved if they aren't
changed but the problems are that when
when parents have a child like this they
often are head the wits ends about
trying to figure out what's going on the
doctors can't diagnose them it's not a
problem mistake that the doctors are
making these are very heterogeneous
maybe thousands of different causes and
they don't have names on there and they
have general often similar phenotypes or
similar symptoms so what happens is the
parents do
no the doctors don't know they go from
one doctor to the other to the other
they spend years on doing lots of
testing sometimes they're these are the
best invasive tests you can't learn make
any kind of prediction if you don't know
the cause about how this is going to
progress or what's going to happen
certainly don't have much that you can
do for treatment other than trying to
treat the symptoms we don't know
anything about how to treat how to think
about new therapies if we don't know the
causes parents are trying to decide do I
want to have more children are not given
that we've had this problem and of
course there's a serious problem or
parents feeling that it's their fault so
if you can figure out the the causes of
these it's extremely helpful even if you
can't help that the person the child or
the individual with their clinical
outcome at least it helps in some of
these problems and as I'm going to tell
you we've actually are able to
accomplish both in some cases we
actually do have a impact on the
clinical health on the on the treatment
outcomes so we started this project less
than two years ago we're calling it the
Hudson alpha pediatric genetics project
is to recruit 450 children who have
these disorders that are not down
syndrome rett syndrome fragile x
syndrome the other ones for which we
know the cause as these are the
unexplained ones that do not have a
diagnosis we're also we creating both
parents and consented both parents and
one thing that we're doing in its our
first cases of doing this where we're
also now both doing research on the how
to deliver the information back to
parents and physicians and patients as
well as actually doing that returning
the information so this this is a group
of a from dr. Martina Devon led leads
the clinic here in Huntsville North
Alabama children specialist she has more
than 1800 patients in her clinic showing
you that this is a you know widespread
problem we're also working with dr. Cal
brothers at University of Louisville who
is a bioethicists as well as a physician
and he's studying how do we best return
this information to maximize
helping the families and the patients
and the physicians and then our group
here as i mentioned led by by greg
cooper where we do the sequencing data
analysis and interpretation so this
slide it may be a little confusing we're
about 200 trios into that sequencing
both the children in both the children
and both parents we're finished
sequencing a couple hundred of those and
i've only fully analyzed about 120 of
them showing you what are pointing out
what one of the big issues here is the
sequencing now it's not that it's
trivial but it's quite straightforward
we have with shawn levy's team have a
very very high quality very rapid
sequencing and even primary analysis of
calling all the variants but then
figuring out which one's of these might
be the cause our contributor to the
child's phenotypes that's the hard part
this interpretation part and that's
where we spend much of our time and
money but if you look at these numbers
here actually on the left it says no
bearings it's not quite true what it
means is that and i should say these
first hundred twenty-one families are
just exomes we started out doing exome
sequencing once we bought in december
into the into the alumina x10 system
where we can sequence whole james
genomes cheaper than we can the exams we
started sequencing them so we haven't
analyzed the whole genomes or
interpreted them are yet or they're not
shown on these slides of course these
individuals is fifty-seven percent
individuals do have variance we are
sequence variants but there were none
that were were suggested to be
pathogenic how you determine whether
something is pathogenic or not is a
complicated and important problem that
our whole field is working on grant
cooper is an expert working with
colleagues in seattle jason terry in
particular and expert in helping to
figure out those kinds of you know does
this sequence variant is base change but
base pair change is that likely to cause
harm to the g not to the individual to
the gene so that's one of the big
problems Liz worthy one of our new
faculty members about who is moving here
in about a month is also an expert in
doing that kind of
analysis of interpretation but even if
you take the weaknesses that we have
there now and look at them almost 40% of
them of the individuals that we sequence
we're getting a definite or likely
diagnosis we're figuring out a gene that
is the cause our contributor to their
phenotype so seventeen percent are
absolutely we know are pathogenic and
feel very confident eight percent are
almost a hundred percent confident and
this V us stands for variant of unknown
significance these are variants that
clearly harm a gene but we don't know
yet whether they're ones that actually
cause the phenotype if you think about
this these are rare disorder sometimes
very rare disorders and very the loss of
function mutations that we're finding in
these chains may have never been seen
before but as the databases and
throughout the world get populated and
as long as people share data which they
hope we hope they will we'll start
finding these occurring more and more
than one individual and the sort of
thought here is that occurring in three
individuals with the similar phenotype
is is enough to make the call that it is
indeed the pathogenic cause of the
disorder it's a little harder for
dominant mutations but but that's part
of the problem as well this is exciting
because we're about the only ones doing
this obviously by the way our group is
one of the big groups and the group
joining us from Wisconsin are very big
and doing this so we're doing this for
research making discoveries every one of
these genes that is new genes that is
found is a biological problem to study
as well and I will say well I i well let
me just show you a couple of days
they're here a couple of examples where
where Greg and his team found the actual
cause and so one of them was a girl who
had mild intellectual delay but but was
not diagnosed with rett syndrome which
is relatively rare but but a well-done
usually easily diagnosed syndrome the
physician seeing this girl are very good
at this they know rett syndrome they
know how to diagnose these disorders but
this girl had a typical symptoms and
yeah
when we sequence turn she had a mutation
in Becky to which is known to be causing
that particular disorder it was a it was
a milder mutation and that knowledge may
allow the physicians in the family to
provide their daughter with with you
know some treatment options and had not
been thought of before here's another
example where we had two unrelated
individuals here enhance or new had a
mild intellectual delay as well no
seizures but they in their genes were
sequence when their genome with sequins
are the exome mutations are found and
clearly they had mutations in a gene
Minh that in others are known to cause
seizures in fact usually really severe
seizures so these children were then
analyzed by EEG and sure enough or just
some clinical procedure for having
seizures and and are now being treated
to help prevent the seizures from ever
having an onset and the consequent
possible brain damage that comes from
that then there now this beta our data
have grown in Howard Jacob and his group
from from Wisconsin coming here have
have three twice as much of those data
and in multiple cases that we're finding
examples where knowing the answer now
has an impact on the clinical outcome in
a few cases incredibly dramatic impacts
of saving saving lives it's not that it
happens every time but it does happen
enough to make this absolutely both
rewarding and worthwhile one of the
things because we're seeking sequencing
both parents is that we get what we call
incidental findings and that means
mutations in genes and this is a little
controversial what is actionable but you
can debate this forever but if you get
if you have a mutation in a brca1 or 2
gene and your female you might want to
at least know it and you might want to
do something about it preventive or
otherwise or certainly increase
surveillance lots of places where there
are many genes where if you have a
mutation and them usually loss of
function ones that you would have a
cardiovascular problem and you might
want to watch after it we've had three
cases where people had mutations
in the ryanodine receptor gene which if
you have a mutation loss of function in
that gene it's a Calcutta coach encodes
a calcium channel you get something
called malignant hyperthermia if you get
particular types of anesthesia which are
actually commonly used your temperature
goes up to 112 degrees and often die on
the operating table so two of these
adults we found unrelated in different
mutations in the genes are now wearing
bracelets or at least having to warn
their positions that they are at risk
for this disorder all right now I'm
going to tell you about how we've
applied in a big collaboration genomics
to identify causes or at least
contributors to disease so this is lou
gehrig's disease RALs many of you know
about it it's actually about it but five
or six thousand cases in the US
diagnosed every year people live with
this disease for 4 22 23 24 years
usually and so and it's constantly
recurring mutations happening so we
started a project with biogen idec in
cambridge massachusetts led by dr. tim
harris he's a bunch of genetics program
there and then collaborating with David
Goldstein and his group when they were
at Duke University David and it is many
of us before now in Columbia and then
our group here in Hudson alpha I will
say this was led by Liz cerulli
scientists and David's group and
Brittany lasane a postdoc in my group
and they working closely together with
each other with the genome services lab
here and Shawn Levy and Tim Harris's
team did it did this large project that
we just recently published it's not
impressed it's actually out we sequence
about 3,000 individuals with ALS this
was X on which we certainly do whole
genome to hell because it would be
cheaper and then had more than 6000
controls we got some findings based on
those by doing a burden analysis that we
identified genes that we were likely
contributors to disorder we followed up
with custom capture sequencing of
additional cases and control
and then analyze them for the disease
the disorder August and disease burden
but for things like a chub onset and
gender excedrin and what happened on
this next slide you can see it was a
little fuzzy apologized you can see in
this in this QQ plot you see when you
get off the diagonal here those are
potential genes are those are
contributors and so we identified a
dozen or more that are genes that are
contributors to this disorder sometimes
even out not causes in the upper right
corner there you may not be able to read
it but that's sod1 that's actually well
the first known cause our gene to be
identified years ago as main cause of
this disorder so it was gratifying that
we got the known gene because we didn't
scream the patient's out for those and
we got them in and expected frequencies
one so we published this recently in
science one of the novel genes and it
was highlighted in the in the papers tbk
one and it's a it's a protein that
interacts with up to nuran and these
other genes to other two genes have
known to be associated with ALS and
these genes and it play a role in
autophagy inflammation which i guess is
involved in almost and many many disease
phenotypes but a lot is known about this
and there's some functional analysis of
this and model systems that has
corroborated that this is clearly a new
target and the idea behind the reason by
engine which was and is interested they
were converted generated disorders the
reason they're interested in this kind
of project and they funded this as an
academic style project than the data
published and released and available
which i think is quite noble of them but
the reason they're interested is that
they're looking for new targets these
disorders are very very hard to manage
and anything that helps to give an idea
of how you might do therapy is extremely
helpful and especially when they tie
into a pathway where where multiple
members of the pathway are involved and
truthfully some of these could be useful
for other kinds of diseases
that have similar phenotypes not just
necessarily ALS okay I'm going to now
talk about gene expression so now
instead of genetics I'm talking about
how I kind of artificially break this
into into into genomics this is
functional genomics and I think we all
know it known for a long time that you
can look at messenger RNAs for example
and you can see differences between
different individuals different tissues
and certainly the same tissue diseased
and non-diseased so clearly this
variation in expression is important and
it contributes to the phenotypes that we
care about so I want to show this
because it's the extent of my talents
and artwork inside engine item that I
get 20 something years ago that we know
that the eukaryotic genome has genes
that are splitted have introns often
they have a start site of transcription
sometimes multiple start sites and right
at the beginning of the genus of course
is where our nape one race and many
components bind to then begin
transcription we know upstream from the
gene within the gene itself and
downstream from the gene their little
segments of sequence that that buying
proteins that also regulate gene
expression and regulate other DNA
processes if you look at what we call
the sis components these are the parts
of the the DNA itself you know we have
we know we have about from the Human
Genome Project and much much work beyond
that we have about 21,000 protein coding
genes we probably identified very close
to all of those there may be some code
for small proteins there are thousands
of and we don't know the real number of
this of non-coding RNA genes and
unfortunately at least for the
scientists that their regulatory
elements these little non-coding
elements that are places where in a
protein spine they're probably a million
or more of those they're spread all
throughout the genome and every gene
will may have multiple of these or does
have multiple of these little segments
that bind proteins the proteins are the
transacting components there we know
that there are at least 1,600 probably
more approach genes that code
proteins that bind to DNA most of those
are probably involved in transcription
obviously others involved in DNA
replication and combination and other
and repair and other processes most of
these recognize little sis acting
elements maybe six base pairs 8 base
pairs so tiny little segments that are
the secret specific data binding
proteins bind to and then some of those
of course histones and the various
versions of histones are in april races
others are general they bind to lots of
places not necessary in a secret
specific manner so if you have any doubt
that transcription is important in human
disease or other disease diseases and
other organisms to this is an old
example a gene found by Lynn Pinocchio
when he was a graduate student in my lab
in the in the mid-90s that what
mutations in this gene lead to a form of
epilepsy and children that's progressive
called progressive myoclonic epilepsy
you found the gene on chromosome 21 it's
a small gene and when you look at
mutations this is a recessive disorder
so you have a mutation for mom and from
damn when you look at mutations or stop
codons splice like new2 mutations etc
but the majority of the cases are
actually a promoter mutation that's
that's um that occurs in almost ninety
percent of the cases every Mendelian
human Mendelian disorder that's been
found with one or two exceptions have
promoter enhancer and other regulatory
mutations so clearly this is just as
important if not more so than the exons
themselves that was at right now maybe
at writing a point because I think
everybody recognizes that but it really
is an issue because we don't know where
all those 1,000,000 segments are and and
it's and it's hard to figure out how
they all work together so I refer to
this is global genomic analysis or
functional genomics where we're looking
at the weed out of the genome and of
course that's messenger RNA all the
other non-coding RNAs like micro RNA
small ones and big ones as well DNA
methylation chromatin Barrett's and all
the different kinds of epigenetic things
that you can have chromatin
accessibility and then proteins that
bind to DNA each of these transcription
factors and
and general factors can we look at these
globally and of course we can now these
are based on sequencing methods like
methyl like a RNA see methyl seek DNA
seek many other methods have been
developed and then what you do is you do
these experiments to look genome-wide at
these events and then try to figure out
what they mean and that's actually
frankly the hard part because we're
having to deal with lots of complicated
data that's not bimodal the way an
allele is either there or not there
whereas all of these are quantitative
events that occur in sometimes in cell
type-specific fashion that makes all of
this complicated nevertheless we and
others in the encode project and others
as well are trying to tack this the best
best we can so let me give a few
examples of looking at this so
transcripts are important clearly here's
a case where Katie Varley who was a
postdoc in my lab now a professor at a
university of utah discovered in breast
cancer big collaboration we have with
physician scientist at university of
alabama birmingham discovered fusion
transcripts in breast cancer seven
transcripts that occur in breast cancer
their breast cancer specific are semi
specific and it's they occur in cases
this is not looking at rearranged
chromosomes like the Philadelphia
chromosome where the DNA has changed in
cancer but where you have two genes
facing in the same direction relatively
short distance between those a few k be
at most probably where you get a
transcript starting in the first gene
and instead of cleaning and doing poly a
addition at the end of this it continues
transcription and it ends up slicing
into the adjacent gene so we call these
treads confusions we published this
recently and here are some of the
information so three of those where we
focused on because they were
particularly interesting all these three
in particular showed a stronger
specificity towards breast cancer as
opposed to other tissues
and the reason this is potentially
interesting for these three is that all
three of them make a few perfusion
proteins where one of the partners is a
transmembrane protein so the hypothesis
of the idea is that you're making a new
protein that's not seen in normal cells
and outside of the cell is a peptide
where the fusion occurs that is not
normally seen in normal cells and so
that's important and potentially
interesting because the idea that you
might be able to use this as a
therapeutic and cancer at least one of
the one of the hopes of being able to
treat and prevent maybe cancer is to do
something where you attack the cancer
cells with antibodies in particular
specifically and so the idea here is to
make an anybody or set of antibodies
that recognize that those aberrant
proteins and because they're outside the
cell the I it's a much easier thought of
how you might deliver the antibody binds
it's taken up into the cell you have a
toxin on the anybody that's been
released some kills the cancer cell so
we're collaborating with the
pharmaceutical company to try to see if
this will actually work so I'm going to
tell you about the protein-dna
interactions this is something near and
dear to me I'm going to be sure I get
through the talk here so I'll speed
through but chip seek is a method
Barbara walls group in my group were one
of the first are several others who a
separate years ago developed this is a
way of really trying to look genome-wide
and where protein we're particularly niz
bound in the DNA so you can we call
these interactome measurements or
genome-wide occupancy measurements and
this is just looking at the long arm
short arm of chromosome 6 you're seeing
little Peaks is a lot of computation and
analysis and controls that go into
getting these data but as you look down
on the lower right and then the lower
left to higher and higher resolution you
can actually get one of the one of these
little Hills here is one place where
that particular transcription factor
that is there for five of five or six of
them
here where each of those factors are
bound so you can get this snapshot of
where a protein that you're interested
in interacts so we're doing this is our
the encode project there's only one of
the many things that encode assume we've
been part of this group for a long time
this is an encyclopedia of DNA elements
and this is similar to the human genome
project a project where it's a
consortium it's a group of scientists
generate large amounts of data for DNA
protein interactions for RNA for for
dnase hypersensitivity etc all of these
types of events does them in a
standardized way with with the right
kinds of controls etc and then releases
that data for absolutely free immediate
use by anybody in the community and and
we know try to learn as much of it as we
can ourselves but but thousands of users
are using this information and it really
is a community sort of project where
we're providing this was meant to be a
service to provide this to the community
and is having a huge impact many of
these regions are ones that are involved
in disease for instances but also for
basic biology people or many many people
are using them so that's where we're
doing a lot of our chipsy and it's the
hardest part about should seek is
finding a good antibody weave between
the groups that were can encode and then
even taking the entire rest of the world
that is doing this we're probably
representing only about a quarter of all
the all the transcription factors may be
a little bit more than that now so we're
really working hard to try to find more
of these and it's been diminishing
returns because it's hard to get good
anybody some of these may not may not
even be immunogenic enough to do it so
we started tagging the transcription
factors and cell lines in recent months
this is being done with Eric Mendenhall
at university of alabama in huntsville
here and an hour encode group barbara
walters group others etc and so you add
a tag to the gene you and I using crispa
you're you're tagging the endogenous
gene so you get normal levels of
expression center we we've started doing
this and we've done it for you know
modest number so far about 20 so far but
are trying to up to speed to
turn this into a pipeline to do this for
hundreds of the not many hundreds of
them and the thing that's gratifying at
least so far will we have done this with
protein transcription factors that we
know that we do have good antibodies for
we compared the antibody version which
we're calling white wild-type year
versus the flag or the tag version and
they look almost identical so we think
that this is a robust and a very very
good way to do this so we're applying it
a bunch of those for which we had never
gotten anyone I will brag on Dan sabic
postdoc in my laboratory very talented
post factory was experimentally amazing
but also works and analyze lots of data
and he figured out a way we were trying
to do chip in in a chip seek in tissues
lots of different tissues human and
mouse and could not get any invent one
or two published methods to be robust or
reproducible enough and so he developed
a method where it's very simple you just
have to keep everything cold you have to
put the tissues in a very non
destructible bang that particular ones
made by Cabarrus and then hammer it with
a with a hammer multiple times to
pulverize the tissues this now has led
to lots of measurements and many
different tissues by our group and
others that are reproducible very very
powerful method even though it seems so
simple okay a couple more more points
and then I will end DNA methylation we
measured this genome wide web by a
variety of methods and Brittany lasane
and Jim Brooks Jim Brooks is a colleague
of former colleague at Stanford
University of neurologists and
researcher working on kidney cancer and
prostate cancer so Jim identified our
story isolated 135 tumors from
individuals who had renal cell carcinoma
and he had also matched non-tumor kidney
tissues from each of those individuals
so Brittany measured DNA methylation in
all of those samples genome Y and then
analyzed the data and compare normal
which this has gotten out of shifted out
of
back here I'm sorry but normal versus
versus the tumors themselves and
identify DNA methylation markers about
20 of them that absolutely distinguish a
tumor from non-tumor so if you look at
this next plot on the left here we have
an ROC curve if you don't know what
these mean if when you're looking at
whether test is going to be valid about
you want the area under this curve to be
as close to one as possible and the red
one which is overlapping with the blue
one but the red one is her data that
gave an ROC curve at point nine nine
which is almost unheard of to get one
that good so her 20 markers were
absolutely capable of distinguishing
this is can you sell renal cell
carcinoma versus not and even even for
all different subtypes of renal cell
carcinoma there's several they're not
and then a few months ago TCGA the
Cancer Genome Atlas Project published
data released their data wasn't a
publication released their data and
Brittany was able to do the same thing
and look at it and it ended very very
highly replicated the results so we
believe these are real so what if any we
knew these retainers so does it do any
good to do that kind of measurement well
if you already know somebody has a tumor
if it actually would be helpful in the
biopsy or after the timbers removed to
actually learn something about it from
the looking at these markers because
they do distinguish some of the subtypes
of each other some of the markers do and
some of them actually have predictive
power for whether the trigger is going
to recur non which would affect a
treatment but the real reason this would
be valuable is that we can find these
methylated DNA s in the urine or blood
from breakdown in the cells where
furiously trying to do that others are
as well we're trying to apply that in
that matter because then you could
imagine that being a screening tool to
see whether someone has kidney cancer
not this with mrs. treat for kidney of
pancreatic ovarian many other cancers
we're certainly early detection of any
cancer would be helpful but those three
that I mentioned
particularly bad in that you often get
big tumors already having spread by the
time you get symptoms so this is on this
is helpful zone alright okay the last
thing I want to tell you about is using
genomics genomic kinds of measurements
and we do this mostly with RNA seek and
with methyl seat kind of methods to see
whether you can predict whether
someone's going to respond to a drug or
not this the pharmacogenetics and
genomics a question that many are
interested in I think this is one of the
most essential II one of the most
powerful approaches in genomics and and
I'm just going to show two cases here
where again this was done by Katie
Varley when she was in the lab working
with these these physician scientist
said in Birmingham and she basically
found in one of their drug trials that
they did it at UAB they found it was an
antibody drug to the death cell receptor
and they had women they were in this
trial for breast cancer women were
treated with this and you had women who
responded they were sensitive to it and
they were resistant to it and you don't
have to really understand very much to
see that those two groups had very
different methylation patterns so some
of these genes are actually interesting
for from the breast cancer point of view
and even potentially new targets but
that alone is a potential diagnostic
tool that could be used to determine
whether you'll have a responder and even
better when was one where we're at UAB
the trial was done with the combination
of two drugs that have not been used
before again with breast cancer and this
is er positive breast cancer and Katie
found very strong signatures from women
and responded versus those who didn't
respond and some of the responders were
actually super responders so this was
strong enough to warrant a larger
clinical trial clinical trials are
expensive this was done on a small
number of individuals expanding the
trial and where I think most of us see
this going is that you get you use the
the test itself the genomic signatures
like the ones we show here to choose
the people who will be in the trial
because they're likely to be responders
and that increases your chance at the
trial will work okay so I've given you a
kind of an overview of the kinds of
things that we in our Institute and our
collaborators and our labs here do and
and mostly in human health and disease
this last slide just shows I do very
little this work I help to coordinate in
and interact with lots of collaborators
and it's great fun doing this kind of
work thanks for your attention I'm happy
to answer questions great thank you so
much for that informative presentation
dr. Myers before we get started on the
question answer session I would like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is from Thomas from the
from Planet connect could promoter
regions become d methylated to change
from being silent to being on kochanek
yes so certainly you get methylation
changes happening in normal human
biology and especially in cancer so that
absolutely happens where where you see
changes and often it is in promoters but
it can be in other regulatory regions
that are that are distant from the gene
where where they get either
hypermethylated so they usually in
promoters when you methylate that means
the gene is shut down and so that
certainly occurs in cancer and other
other sort of normal events like an
aging as well as other diseases
okay so it looks like those that was the
only submitted question so we'll go
ahead and wrap up thank you dr. Myers
again for that presentation today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through november 2016 you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye